Thermals — how do thermals form?
We have the sun, as we've already discussed — it's the engine of the weather.
The sun shines on the Earth's surface and warms the air layer near the ground.
Accordingly, there's a slightly warmer layer of air at the ground.
That's really important to understand for thermals.
When we're flying or looking for thermals, we always have to ask ourselves,
which air mass, or rather which ground, warms up more than the other.
It's always about a temperature difference.
It doesn't have to be warm per se — in winter we can also fly thermals.
If the forests, for example, are snow-free, they warm up more than a snow-covered meadow slope.
So the thermals are to be found over the forest.
So the temperature difference is always really important.
It also has to do with the albedo effect, because some surfaces warm up more strongly than others.
For example, there's a dry field that's been harvested.
It warms up more than a green meadow that maybe is still damp.
So you always have to ask which surface warms up more.
And there's also the basic rule — the more reflective a surface is,
snow for example, the less it actually warms up.
Or a black surface, a dark surface, of course warms up a lot more,
because it absorbs much more heat from the sun's rays.
Another thing that's really important for warming is the sun's angle of incidence.
Ideally, the sun's rays that we see here
hit a surface at a right angle.
That way the surface gets warmed much more strongly
than a surface that's tilted, where the sun's rays only hit at a shallow angle.
Think for example again of the polar regions and the tropical regions.
That also has to do only with the angle of incidence of the sun.
Accordingly, a warm air layer forms at the ground, which builds a bubble.
And the warm air layer, when it has enough temperature difference,
and is released by a small trigger,
detaches and starts to rise.
You can picture it a bit like a lava lamp.
This air mass stays closed.
That's again an air mass.
It's an air mass with a uniform property.
It's warmer than the air mass around it.
And it rises away.
So here we have two air masses.
We have the atmosphere outside, which has a certain temperature,
which we'll also briefly touch on.
And the warm air layer that rises.
The bubble that rises.
And forms the thermal.
You can also picture a hot-air balloon.
It also rises because it has warmer, warm air,
which is less dense.
And so the hot-air balloon rises.
The same is true of the thermal,
of this thermal bubble that rises.
Again, we have a certain air pressure
that prevails in our atmosphere.
We have higher air pressure in the lower region
than in the upper layers.
Now we come back to air pressure.
You can see, we're starting to tie things together.
Accordingly, when a balloon like this rises —
some of you may know this from diving.
Or with a weather balloon you see it very impressively.
When it's down low,
it has a very small volume of the gas inside it.
When it rises, where the air pressure here drops,
then the gas can expand more and more.
And so the volume increases,
of the air parcel that's rising.
And then we come to the cooling.
When the balloon rises,
there's a decompression,
the pressure of the rising air parcel drops.
It expands, the pressure drops.
And when in an air mass, or in a gas generally, the pressure drops,
then the temperature decreases.
You see this very impressively, for example,
with a compressed-air gun —
when you blow air out, it's ice cold.
That basically only has to do with the fact
that the compressed air from the compressor
expands very quickly and cools down as a result.
So an air mass that expands cools down.
Accordingly, the opposite is also true.
When an air mass is compressed,
it warms up.
You also see this in practice, for example,
when you pump up a tyre.
When you pump up a pressurised tyre,
at some point it gets really warm.
And that's because you're compressing a lot of air there.
Always keep this picture in mind.
It's really important for various meteorological phenomena,
including thermals here.
If you look at the numbers,
you can imagine
that the ground starts at 20 degrees.
These are just approximate numbers.
And then it rises
and the temperature decreases more and more with altitude.
Exactly.
That has to do with decompression
and with this air mass rising.
In the end, if we just picture it,
in the atmosphere we have
a certain temperature gradient.
Ideally it gets colder and colder with altitude.
The air mass here is sitting at night, for example.
At night the air mass flows here.
It's a bit warmer at ground level
than higher up.
On Mount Everest it's much colder
than down at the sea, for example,
just to picture it visually.
And there you have the temperature gradient,
which is again a progression,
a gradient,
a temperature gradient of this air mass,
which is just sitting here.
And now in the morning the sun comes up,
the engine of the weather starts to work,
starts to heat up the surfaces on the ground
and the thermals rise away
and cool down.
And through the cooling process,
the thermal usually
reaches a point somewhere
where it's just as cold
as the surrounding air.
Now here in this case, the thermal top
is reached at the point
where the air mass is at minus two degrees.
And the surrounding air,
where you're sitting right there,
is at a certain point
exactly as cold
as the parcel that's rising.
Accordingly,
the hot-air balloon no longer has any temperature advantage
and it won't rise any further.
The thermal stops at a certain point.
Exactly,
that has to do with the temperature state curve,
as it's also called.
The temperature state curve describes
really just the atmosphere,
that is, the stratification of the air mass,
as it sits there.
The cooling
that takes place here
is also described
as an adiabatic process
or as adiabatic cooling.
And there are two of them,
which I'll get into in a moment.
And you can imagine
that the surrounding air mass
has a certain state.
Here it's just shown a bit differently,
so you can picture
that there are two different air masses —
that's really important.
There's very little mixing going on between them.
And especially the way
you want to learn it for the theory exam,
that's the most relevant point.
There's also a Meteo Advanced course,
where we get into thermal theory in much more detail.
There are also other effects there
that are relevant,
but for the basic theory course
they go way too far.
Exactly,
now we see the temperature decrease
that makes the air parcel rise.
And there's a second factor that comes in,
which for us as pilots is really very important.
And that's humidity.
In an air parcel we have —
and right now in this room here too —
we have a certain proportion of water vapour.
So we don't only have oxygen and nitrogen,
but we also have a certain water-vapour content
in our air parcel.
Humidity,
it's variably moist.
Depending on
what kind of air mass it is.
You can imagine,
with these blue dots,
that's the water vapour in this gas.
And when the air parcel now rises
and cools down,
then the water vapour has less and less room,
you can picture it that way.
And at some point there's the change,
where the air mass can no longer
absorb any more moisture.
And then the gaseous water vapour starts
to change its state of matter into liquid.
Liquid is relative,
because we usually see it as clouds.
So every fog and every cloud is actually nothing other
than water in the air.
And really, really microscopically small water droplets.
It doesn't have to be rain;
it's really, really tiny droplets,
which we perceive,
for our eye, more like a gas.
But they're really water droplets in the air.
And then we talk about condensation.
The condensation level,
where the air mass starts to condense,
the water vapour that's in there.
A word we also hear again and again
is the relative humidity,
which then increases.
And at 100 percent of course we've reached the point
where the air mass can no longer absorb any more moisture.
Exactly.
Then, when the condensation process kicks in,
when the water vapour becomes water,
so when it really turns into tiny water droplets,
then physically a phenomenon happens,
namely that when it goes from gaseous to liquid,
heat is released.
A little bit of heat is released.
And of course also if it were to change from liquid
into the solid state.
Those are the three states of matter.
After that a little bit of heat is released,
a little bit of energy is released in this process.
The other thing is the opposite of course.
When we have a change of state
from solid to liquid or from liquid to gaseous,
then heat is consumed.
An important point in this condensation process
is the back-of-the-envelope calculation
we're just looking at here.
And that's important for you
to understand what's roughly happening here.
When the air mass rises, it cools down.
As long as it rises dry-adiabatically,
that is, without any condensation process taking place,
it's very simple.
It's just 1 degree per 100 metres.
So when it rises,
it cools down by 1 degree per 100 metres
in this thermal bubble.
That's very simple.
You can remember that number.
In the moist-adiabatic process
the back-of-the-envelope calculation starts.
Specifically, we have the 1 degree per 100 metres
by which it cools.
But working against that is the condensation process,
which always releases a bit of energy
in the form of heat.
And so here of course
a certain amount is subtracted
from those degrees per 100 metres,
which in the end comes out to roughly
0.65 degrees per 100 metres.
The value, as you can see here,
isn't always exactly the same.
That has to do with the fact
that a warm air mass
can absorb more moisture
than a cold one.
In a warm air mass we have correspondingly
more moisture that starts to condense
than in a colder air mass,
for example in polar regions.
So the value
varies a little.
But for you it's important to know
that it's simply smaller than 1 degree.
Here's the back-of-the-envelope calculation
of moist-adiabatic cooling.
You can remember these two numbers.
And now let's look at
what that means in practice.
Now we see the air mass
rising here below.
In this case a dry-adiabatic cooling
with 1 degree per 100 metres.
At a certain point
the rising air mass reaches
the condensation level.
The condensation process
begins.
And so the air mass cools
now, in this case, only by
0.65 degrees per 100 metres.
That's the moist-adiabatic process.
That keeps going
until, as we had before,
the air parcel has the same temperature
as the surrounding air.
Those are the two
adiabatic cooling processes
you need to know.
Then we have an image here maybe
from practice,
from flight practice.
You see the landscape.
You have to ask yourself: where does
the air mass rise best?
Or much more importantly: where does
the ground warm up the most?
That's right-angled sun exposure.
Maybe a ground that warms up a bit more
than the ground around it.
In this case the meadow areas
certainly warm up a bit more
than a forest.
On the south-facing slope, at some point the thermal lifts off.
It rises, it rises, it rises
and at some point it forms
beautiful cumulus clouds
that mark the thermals.
If of course we also
have wind on top of that,
if we picture a balloon
rising, then of course it drifts
into the wind, with the wind.
And so it's
a puzzle when you come here
for cross-country flying — where do I fly to?
You always have to piece together
where the thermal lifts off
and where it forms a nice little cloud.
Another important point:
the thermal, the thermal air mass
that rises, doesn't always have to
form a little cumulus cloud.
It can also be that the
temperature advantage of the thermal —
I'm thinking of the balloon — is exhausted,
so that it has equalised,
before a condensation process
takes place. Then over here
there might be exactly the same — over there
exactly the same thermal, but it has
stopped rising before
it condensed. And so
we talk about blue thermals.
That's the term you can remember.
Blue thermals are actually nothing other
than thermals that never condensed.
Right. A term for thermals
that you also hear from time to time
is the term lee thermal.
We had it before — windward
and leeward. The lee side,
the side of the mountain facing away from the wind.
If we picture a wind here,
this is the side facing away from the wind
of these mountains. Maybe we have
sun exposure that warms
exactly these surfaces,
the angle of the sun,
more than the other side.
And so the thermal lifts off best there.
And so we speak of a lee thermal.
So a thermal that's there at the end,
on the side facing away from the wind.
That happens of course mostly
when, for example, we have a north wind
in the Alps.
Because the south side of the mountains
in the Alps always warms up best.
So south-facing slopes are best.
If we now have a north wind, or a Bise,
on top of that for example,
then the wind comes from the north.
And so the lee thermal
is very pronounced.
Lee thermals usually have the property
of being more turbulent.
So lee rotors, mechanical turbulence.
You see, we're tying more and more things together.
We have mechanical turbulence here
that of course chops up the thermal.
It's a bit like a shredder
that, depending on wind strength, makes the thermal
more turbulent.
But usually the lee thermal is also
a bit stronger.
Because the air parcels in the lee,
in the wind-sheltered area,
could heat up for longer.
And so they're much warmer
than a windward thermal for example.
So if we had
the other wind direction,
then the air parcel
gets carried away by the wind again and again.
And so
the air mass on the windward side
can't heat up as long
as a lee thermal.
Now that's something
that's already a bit advanced,
but good to know.
What's important is that you know
what a lee thermal is.
Now we move on
from the temperature state curve —
that's really important —
of the air mass that rises,
and we're talking about the air mass
that just sits there,
which formed during the night,
just the state of the whole air mass
that lies over Switzerland at this moment.
And from this point on
we really only talk about the air mass
that's sitting there, not about the thermal any more.
The air mass can be various things.
Ideally, or normally,
the warm air mass is at the bottom
and it gets colder and colder
the higher you go.
For example with an unstable stratification.
You can imagine that
when the hot-air balloon rises,
the temperature advantage
can be sustained for much longer,
because it's getting colder above,
than if we had the opposite,
the so-called inversion.
There are, with certain weather situations,
with high-pressure influence for example,
inversions,
the other way round,
where we often have cold at the bottom
and on the mountaintops we have very warm.
You sometimes get that in winter,
when there are strong inversions.
In Zurich by the lake it's cold,
you sit in the fog down below,
and on the peaks above, while skiing
it's the most beautiful, warmest weather,
where you can almost sit out at a table.
That's a so-called inversion.
And now you can imagine,
when the thermal rises up into an inversion,
where it often gets warmer with altitude,
we no longer have any temperature advantage.
After that the air mass basically stops rising.
And so we talk about
a very stable stratification.
That's a stable stratification,
with too little thermal activity to expect.
Very calm air masses too.
You get really milky conditions.
Beautiful for hike-and-fly and so on,
but not so beautiful for thermal flying.
Down below there's the middle range,
a so-called isothermal layer,
as it's called.
That's when the temperature state
stays exactly the same with altitude.
If we have 6 degrees in the valley below
and 6 degrees up on the mountain,
then that's a so-called isothermal layer,
a constant air stratification.
Exactly.
But the temperature state in the atmosphere
is definitely such that it's warm below
and gets colder with altitude.
Now there are a few exam questions here
about this inversion
or unstable air stratification etc.,
where you'll see a temperature gradient
written out in text form —
at 500 metres it's 15 degrees,
at 800 metres it's 14 degrees etc.
It's listed out like that.
And now of course you'll often be asked,
where is there a surface inversion?
Then you have to think:
I'm looking down here at 500 metres,
and an inversion, ah,
is a reversed air stratification.
That means it gets warmer with altitude.
Then you just have to read the numbers here.
For example, here 1 is 15 degrees
and at 800 metres it's 16 degrees.
That's getting warmer, that's an inversion.
The same with a high-altitude inversion,
the same thing takes place,
just at higher altitudes.
Or an isothermal layer,
for example here at 4, where we have 8 degrees
at both altitudes —
that's a constant air stratification.
So that's an example exam question.
Then we come to the next chapter,
which is important.
Here we open up the chapter on
cloud names, cloud shapes,
cloud pictures, and what that means for us.
With clouds it's like this —
as in this diagram,
there are lots of Latin names
and it's sometimes very complicated
to remember and to know what they mean.
It's a real maze.
Now we'll try to sort it out
and see how it comes about.
For cloud names,
in my head I make
a 2-by-3 grid
and then there's also a box
for special clouds
that don't fit into this grid,
but you can imagine a 2-by-3 grid.
Then fundamentally there are two types
of cloud families.
One is the cumulus cloud,
a cumulation,
a cumulus point,
an accumulation of something —
these are heap clouds.
Heap clouds is what they're called,
everything that has a cumulus-cloud form.
Then there's stratus,
which is a layer cloud.
Everything that's fog, for example,
is a proper layer cloud.
Everything that's so nicely spread out
in horizontal cloud fields.
The two cloud families differ
mainly in that cumulus clouds
form primarily
when very strong
vertical air-mass movements
take place, so when a thermal rises
for example, or when in high
air layers an air layer is forced
to rise.
Then you get cumulus cloud forms.
Cumulus cloud forms.
With stratus it's the opposite.
That actually points more to
a stable air mass,
where there's little vertical motion in it,
and rather a horizontal cloud,
that just settles in a bit.
Just for understanding,
what happens with these two cloud forms.
On the side we have
storeys,
the various altitudes of clouds.
There we have cirro-clouds.
Ice crystals.
That's a very high altitude.
They basically only consist of ice crystals.
Then we have the alto storey.
That's a high cloud layer.
That's roughly between 4 and 7 kilometres.
And then we have the ground level,
where actually you only have the basic cloud families.
You'll see in a moment
where actually no additional name is added.
The altitudes
are always relative.
They vary a bit.
They might be 3 kilometres
or 8 kilometres. It's not fixed.
It's not a precisely defined altitude.
But what's important is that
alto clouds are really clearly above
2000 to 3000 metres.
And cirro clouds are really above 8 kilometres.
So very, very high clouds.
And now we can actually just start
putting the names of these
different clouds together.
You see, you just have to combine them.
There's cirrocumulus.
That's made up of these two names.
Then there's cirrostratus.
That's a milky soup
that's very, very high up.
That's usually what gives you a halo.
So a circular rainbow
at very high altitude.
That's cirrostratus.
That's a layer cloud again.
Then we have altocumulus
and altostratus.
Down below we have cumulus and stratus.
Those are then just the basic forms.
That's also important.
Cumulus and altocumulus differ
mainly in that cumulus
forms through sun exposure.
That's really the thermal updraft,
as we just discussed.
When a colder air layer
pushes underneath,
then the warm air layer starts to rise away
and forms small cumulus clouds.
Everything on the left-hand side
points to an unstable air stratification.
The air is very eager to rise.
There we have unstable, stable again.
Everything on the right we tend to call
a stable air stratification.
So the air isn't very eager to rise.
And we tend to find
more inversions
with stratus clouds.
Those are the two cloud families.
They get combined
and built up from these two.
It's very simple,
how it can be sorted into this grid.
Then of course we still have a few special clouds.
We have a few special cases too.
One cloud in the stratus range
is the so-called nimbostratus.
Nimbus stands for rain.
So layer clouds
that really rain themselves out.
We often have this with a warm front
or in a low-pressure area,
where it's just chucking it down,
where it's just raining.
That's usually a nimbostratus.
So precipitation.
Then we have cirrus clouds,
so without an addition.
Cirrus clouds are feather clouds.
These are very high, classic feather clouds.
For us, for flying, they're not so relevant either.
For us, for flying, that's also not so relevant.
Then we have lenticularis,
a really interesting cloud,
which we'll get into now.
And for us one of the most important clouds
is the CB, or cumulonimbus.
That's the fully developed
thunderstorm cloud.
It flashes and thunders and rains
and for us is really the most dangerous.
It extends really
from the lower storey
up to the tropopause.
We'll come to that in a moment.
And logically there are also
lots of special clouds
and detailed names
you can geek out about.
But for you, for normal flying,
what matters is just the basics — the rest doesn't really matter.
We don't need to go any deeper into it.
On the topic of clouds
there's also the degree of cloud cover,
which you read again and again in the weather report
or in gliding
in the weather report etc.
There we always talk about eighths.
So 8 eighths cover
is a closed cloud cover.
We don't see any blue sky,
it's all closed up.
0 eighths, logically no clouds,
maybe only blue thermals,
if there are any thermals at all.
There could also be blue thermals there —
we've tied it together again.
2 eighths is covered,
2 eighths of the sky are covered
and the other 6 eighths
are blue and clear.
And of course 4 eighths is half-cloudy.
4 eighths is actually a nice cloud cover
for us for thermal flying.
Something between 3 and 4 eighths,
because we have nice cumulus clouds
and here we still have enough blue sky,
so the sun can heat up the ground,
so we have nice weather,
so the thermals develop.
That's the degree of cloud cover.
A really interesting cloud form,
lenticularis,
is probably the one most pilots know,
or that you've quickly seen at some point.
Lenticularis actually needs
two or three ingredients.
One is a mountain range,
another is a very strong wind.
Lenticularis clouds always indicate
a very, very strong wind.
And of course we need
a bit of humidity,
so it can also start to condense.
That happens usually either
directly over the mountain peaks
or on the lee side of the mountain range.
These are rotors
that put the air into a wave motion
and so always,
at the top of this wave motion,
the rising air mass condenses,
such a cloud forms,
behind it the air sinks again,
it stops condensing
and then you get these wave clouds.
What's important for us to know about flying:
this is a very strong wind,
but because the mountain range
always stays in the same place
and the waves accordingly
always stay in the same place,
this is important for us.
Just because a cloud stays in place
doesn't mean there's no wind.
Logically.
But you certainly know these cloud forms
very well by sight
and for all paraglider pilots
they're always an alarm signal,
when you see lenticular clouds.
Then we have a really important topic,
which is the wind.
That's a really important topic,
Then we have a really important topic
for paraglider pilots,
which is thunderstorms.
With thunderstorms it's like this:
a thunderstorm is nothing other
than a cumulus cloud
that has grown and keeps growing.
It's a really big,
nasty thermal cloud.
That's what makes it just as
dangerous for us,
because of course we want to fly thermals.
We fly precisely on the days
on which, under certain conditions,
it keeps flying further.
We have to be careful
when the thunderstorm clouds get too big.
In the morning you see the first cumulus clouds,
we go flying,
by 11 everything's nice,
wonderful flying conditions.
Then the thunderstorm clouds
or cumulus clouds get a bit bigger.
They form of course with the sun.
We always need the engine of the sun.
The engine slowly starts firing.
It's like an engine
that slowly gets going.
We have to slowly get careful,
when the thunderstorm clouds start
to merge.
We have small little clouds here
and suddenly two clouds
merge together.
But we're already talking about large areas,
not a little puffy cloud,
but large clouds
that span a few kilometres.
As soon as the cloud base
starts to merge,
we have to be careful.
Especially when the cloud base
also slowly gets dark.
You can imagine
that because of the water droplets,
and at some point, when the cloud gets tall,
the sun's rays almost can't get through any more.
That's the point where the cloud slowly
starts to appear dark,
where it's also dark under the base.
And that's the point
where you have to slowly start paying attention
and which of course has a lot to do with experience.
How much longer am I flying?
How long do I stay under this cloud?
Is this already a big cloud or not?
That's really an area
where you as an advanced pilot
need a lot of caution.
And another basic rule is,
when all of a sudden everything starts lifting,
now we're flying in the morning,
it was always hard
to find the thermal,
the local updrafts.
And then suddenly everything starts lifting.
Everywhere out in the valley I can fly
and it's lifting and up there is a big cloud.
There you really have to start being careful.
Because then the door
of this thunderstorm slowly starts to run.
And at some point more and more merge
and they get taller and taller.
And it actually doesn't even need any more energy
from the sun,
because the engine immediately starts turning.
Because warm air rises,
cools down, sinks back down.
Because we have cold air,
the warm air just rises faster
and then you get a kind of chain reaction
and a turbo that starts firing.
And the cloud doesn't always grow,
but often up to the tropopause.
And then you get these beautiful
anvil shapes of the cloud.
That's when, when the thunderstorm cloud rises to the top,
you can imagine,
like a Perspex sheet
that lies over it, where the cloud grows up to it
and then can only go sideways
and forms the anvil.
And in this phase, when the thunderstorm is fully developed,
there's a lot of friction in the air mass,
which sinks and rises.
And so sometimes there's lightning
and there's mostly also precipitation.
Uhm, that's it for thunderstorms.
And something I'd really like
to lay on your heart,
everyone is afraid of the thunderstorm
when they're under it.
So the climb rates are extreme,
you really have to be careful there.
Uhm, but what's even more concerning
is the danger
from the outflow of a thunderstorm like that.
The air mass that rises and then
extremely cools down up at 13,000
metres up there,
at some point sinks down
and it's like a bucket of water that gets dumped out.
And accordingly
the cold air empties out
and it's heavy
and cold, so it heads for the ground.
And it can really dump out
and then it goes into the valleys
and down to the landing zones
and it can also cause very strong turbulence
much further away from the thunderstorm.
So that's not only the danger
directly under the thunderstorm,
but really a huge danger
next to the thunderstorm too.
Because the cold-air outflows really go in down below
and that makes the landing extremely turbulent
and dangerous
and very, very unpleasant.
And the cold air or outflows can then,
under certain circumstances, also trigger the next thunderstorm,
where then warm air masses again —
which, for example, are sitting at the valley floor —
the cold air mass comes down,
the warm rises like the weather and then gives
the next turbulence
and maybe even the thunderstorm.
So you really have to be careful
about these cold-air outflows of the thunderstorm.
It's almost more dangerous than the updraft.
So the updraft is also dangerous logically,
but the cold-air outflows are the ones
that unfortunately many pilots underestimate again and again.
When you look at it, it looks like this.
When you see precipitation
under a cloud, then it's the last —
the last,
it's the ultima ratio, to land
or to fly as far away as possible
and then land as soon as possible.
But of course when it looks like this, then it's really no longer good
to fly. That's a proper outflow.
You can really see how the bucket of water
gets dumped out and how massively
cold air gets let out below.
And that really causes a lot of wind.
Then again, the radar, as we've already said.
It's important — look at the radar,
see what's happening.
Look at the cloud below.
If they're clouds, you don't see how high they are up top.
But you might see another cloud
50 kilometres away. And if that's already a huge tower,
then you know that maybe
the cloud everywhere isn't much smaller either.
Then with the radar it's really important —
look at the radar, that's a good thing.
But also, keep your eyes
open outside. The radar image alone is
always a bit delayed and is
sometimes also not exactly what
is everywhere. It can develop very quickly and
that might sometimes not even really be visible on the radar yet.
So always keep your eyes
open and look at what's happening all around.
And what it looks like.
And if it's a medium-sized cloud,
maybe also a little tip.
If it's not yet a thunderstorm,
but just a cumulus cloud you find,
is it already sucking, is it still good or not,
then just fly along the edge of the cloud.
Then you can quickly always get out of
this updraft zone, where you might struggle
to get back down. So better
fly along the edge of the cloud. But obviously
with thunderstorms really be careful.
That has a lot to do with know-how.
And that's sometimes a bit of playing with fire,
when it really comes to thunderstorms.
Right. Then we come
to another important chapter.
The
valley-wind system.
That's a really important phenomenon that, by the way, happens in all
mountain ranges. Including ours
in the Alps. And specifically
we have again — you see,
we keep tying things together —
we have the sun exposure,
which in mountains
can produce much more heat.
Or can warm up better
than in the lowlands.
And so the warming
in the alpine region produces
a
lower air pressure over
the course of the day. And as we
had it, the air mass always wants to equalise pressure.
We have higher pressure
in the lowlands
and lower pressure
in the mountains. And so
there's an equalising flow
over the course of the day.
Careful, that's not to be confused with a
high- or low-pressure area on an isobar chart.
We see, that of course is never
shown that way on an isobar chart. But we have
higher pressure and lower pressure.
But it's exactly the same weather phenomenon
with pressure equalisation, with the
wind system that comes about.
And so there's the equalising flow
over the course of the day.
It's usually strongest,
starting around 11 it kicks in,
it reaches its peak
around 3 in the afternoon.
And in terms of the season, it's like this:
in spring, as soon as
the inner-alpine region
slowly becomes snow-free,
then it slowly starts.
Then it runs through into autumn.
It gets weaker and weaker in summer
towards autumn. But the peak time is
certainly around June, I'd say.
When the thermal activity is also
strongest. So it always needs
thermal activity to trigger it.
Of course if we have an overcast sky
or have inversions,
which don't trigger thermals, then there's
no real valley-wind system either.
Right.
And so at night
you have the opposite.
When a mountain wind sets in,
it usually starts in the evening,
around 6 it kicks in.
Then we often have higher pressure
in the alpine region, because the mountains
cool down faster than the lowlands.
You might know the lowlands.
If you sit by the lake, it stays much longer
still warm than in the mountains, when the sun
slowly goes away. And so we
also again have a pressure difference,
where we have higher pressure in the lowlands,
uh, lower pressure in the lowlands,
sorry. And so
an equalising flow, which around 6
slowly sets in.
And there's the phenomenon
of reverse thermals,
where when the cold air flows out of the mountains,
sometimes the slightly warmer air
in the valley rises away.
There's a kind of reverse thermal,
a convergence that then forms,
usually in the middle of the valley.
And sometimes
at a special spot, for example Interlaken,
there's a really nice updraft,
where you could sometimes fly into the night,
if you were allowed to.
There are special weather phenomena.
But that's the mountain wind that sets in.
By the way, that's also a problem for the take-off
if you have high mountains within the flying area —
then sometimes there's like
a switch that flips in the evening,
the mountain wind, and then sometimes we can hardly get
away from the take-off any more. That's something you sometimes
also have to factor in,
that the mountain wind can also set in.
Right. Then to the
valley wind — that's really important for you to know.
The valley wind can really become a problem in spring,
because it can get very, very strong.
And there's a great valley-wind chart
from the SAV; it has a bit to do with
experience. Main valleys
you can imagine, like a root
of a tree, that merges together.
The further into the main valley you are,
where this root is thick,
the more valley wind we have,
where the main Alpine ridge really gets sucked in.
So the Rhine valley for example, the Rhône valley
and so on, those are all valleys
that can cause very strong valley winds.
Sometimes you can get 50–60 km
per hour of valley wind there.
We're flying thermals in the Valais.
If you go flying in the Valais in June,
then you might have super nice thermal
temperatures.
Up top, the valley wind, that's only in the valley,
it's really in the valley floor,
at 500 metres above the ground, depending.
You can fly thermally up here and then
you have to land in the valley and then
you have a lot of wind. And you really have
to think hard in the main Alpine valleys in spring
about when you have to land just then,
or you might even have to
do a top landing.
That's something you really have to watch out for,
when you fly in the main Alpine valleys.
There are also still some special phenomena
like up at Maloja.
Those are valley winds that spill over,
spill over the pass and then
fall down behind it and also cause very turbulent
air conditions.
Those are very local phenomena,
but you have to inform yourself,
if for example you're flying up at the Grimsel
or at Maloja. You should
really be careful.
So if you fly there, inform yourself
about the valley-wind systems. What's important for your
theory exam is, you have to know
when the valley winds come about
and what times they are.
That's actually what you want to be quizzed on here.
And something you always have to factor in.
Right. Then we come
to another weather phenomenon
that's super, super important for paraglider pilots.
And that's the Foehn.
I always say there are three main dangers
for pilots. It's thunderstorms,
it's the Foehn, and probably
valley winds.
That's another chapter. Because with all
the other weather phenomena, you have strong wind
at the take-off. If a west wind comes,
then you have a really full
west wind at the take-off and then you notice
that maybe it's not such a good idea to launch,
when you have mega wind and you're already struggling,
to get up to launch. Foehn,
thunderstorms and valley wind,
those are actually the only weather phenomena
where on the one side the
flying weather can change extremely quickly —
so it can get very turbulent very quickly —
and on the other side they are
usually also strongest at the landing zone below.
So it can be that you
launch in the valley wind on the mountain above
and have calm conditions, and in the valley below
it's hammering and there's really mega wind.
With Foehn the phenomenon is
exactly the same. So a feeling
for the Foehn — how does it come about,
how much of a wind system,
as we've had it, a pressure equalisation.
We need a pressure difference,
so we need two ingredients for Foehn.
We need a pressure difference
and we need a big mountain range.
That is to say, Foehn
exists in all regions of the world.
It's in the Himalayas, in the Andes,
in the Pyrenees
and here in the Alps.
The Foehn has a different name in each place;
there isn't really a name
that's the same all around the world.
In the Alps the name 'Foehn' has established itself,
and there's a North Foehn and a
South Foehn, so it goes in both
directions of course, back and forth.
For us now on the northern side of the Alps,
of course the South Foehn is the one that causes problems.
Now in this case we have Ticino on the left,
on the right we have the German lowlands
or our pre-Alps.
We have higher pressure on the southern side of the Alps
than on the northern side.
Accordingly,
the air mass wants to equalise the pressure
and flows
over the mountain ridge.
With Foehn maybe still important is,
that depending on the situation
the Foehn gets really sucked in
from the lowlands. You can imagine,
like a vacuum cleaner that pulls air in from behind.
And this air
really wedges into the valleys
and depending on meteorological conditions
really wedges all the way down to the valley floor
and can cause very, very strong winds
down in the valley. There are sometimes special
weather situations where there isn't always much wind
at the take-off, but in a Foehn valley
there's extremely strong wind.
Of course that's what makes it dangerous for us on the northern side of the Alps,
because with Foehn
we usually have lots of sun,
beautiful weather, blue skies, everything is nice,
it would actually be super beautiful for flying,
it would also always be really tempting.
But that's also what makes it just as dangerous with Foehn,
that it comes about precisely in such nice-looking weather.
It comes about, in such a nice weather pattern.
And specifically the air mass rises
in this case on the southern side of the Alps,
it condenses —
we have it again, the air mass rises,
it condenses, forms a cloud,
under certain circumstances it even rains out
and it goes over the main
Alpine ridge, forms a so-called
Foehn wall — that's really like a wall
that follows the main Alpine ridge.
It wedges down,
dries out,
it dissolves the clouds and the dry
warm wind wedges into the lowlands,
into the Alpine valleys
and of course causes very, very strong
turbulence and downdrafts and wind shear
and also the lee rotors,
which under certain circumstances can also form
the lenticularis clouds.
Important: Foehn
doesn't always have to cause rain
in the south, or always have to cause
lenticularis.
Foehn can sometimes be dry
and not show the cloud forms.
That's just the classic Foehn,
how it really usually forms,
when there's a nice damming cloud.
So the pressure difference is mainly important.
On the isobar chart
it looks something like this —
if you look at the rings,
if we had no mountains,
then they would just continue around here,
and just distribute air pressure
evenly.
But now we have the
mountain ridge, the main Alpine ridge,
and you see in the Smali
in the isobars a kink
at the main Alpine ridge,
the so-called Foehn knee, as it's called.
So if you see a kink on an isobar chart
over a mountain range,
really a massive kink,
then it usually has something to do with Foehn,
then you have to start being careful.
And again, as we had it,
where the isobars are closer together,
we have a lot of wind.
Which in this case
ahead of this cold front
brings the Foehn.
By the way, that's a weather phenomenon
that often happens in Switzerland
before a cold front arrives.
But really important: it doesn't always have to be
ahead of a cold front,
you can also get Foehn
without a cold front coming.
But the classic is,
a cold front approaches from the west,
a Foehn knee forms,
you get a Foehn flow
and at some point the front breaks through.
There's a Foehn diagram,
there are various providers,
there's a Foehn diagram,
from the SAV on the MeteoSwiss site,
where we have access,
really very good displays.
This is from the MeteoSwiss Foehn diagram,
where we have in the middle the 0 hPa line,
we always talk about the pressure difference,
when we have an air-pressure station,
a barometer in Ticino
and a barometer in Zurich for example,
and you measure the pressure difference there,
then you also know
whether there could be a balancing flow on one side
or on the other side.
As a rule of thumb, you see the dashed line,
we talk about 4 hPa.
If the
curve swings up,
above 4 hPa,
we talk about South Foehn;
below we talk about North Foehn —
for example here on Saturday and on Friday night
we'd talk more about North Foehn.
And that's very unsettled weather in this forecast,
the pressure swings extremely back and forth
and that always actually means a lot of wind,
lots of motion in the air
and as a rule no good flying weather.
Now it's also important for you to know
that you really read the weather reports well
and that you're aware that the Foehn
sometimes breaks through at 4 hPa.
Sometimes you can also
still fly at 8 hPa,
that's not to be recommended for anybody
and it really has a lot to do with experience
and you also have to know the area very well.
And I really wouldn't recommend
flying in Foehn conditions.
You always hear things like:
I've flown at 8 hPa
in this and that flying area
and it was no problem at all.
It can sometimes break doors down,
sometimes not break doors down.
It has a lot to do
with what direction the Foehn comes from.
It can sometimes be southwesterly,
it can sometimes be a southeasterly Foehn.
That has to do with the temperature stratifications in the air.
It would blow the lecture wide open.
About Foehn you could talk for 2 hours
and philosophise.
What's also important is, if there's a Foehn tendency
around, that you really think hard,
whether you really want to go flying.
And the Foehn has already
caught out a pilot before.
It can really vary a lot.
That's really important.
Also about this curve.
Just because it's at 4 hPa,
doesn't mean there can't be any Foehn.
That's why it's also in Meteo practice,
which we look at in another course,
really important to do with
you looking at wind measurements,
knowing the area well,
looking at the pressure charts,
comparing the forecast values
with reality,
with the actually measured values on the day.
That's all from a computer model.
It doesn't all have to come true that way.
They can also be a bit off.
That has a lot to do with experience.
So be careful with Foehn.
With Foehn it's the case
that the air mass, like water,
like all gases,
wants to take the path of least resistance.
Accordingly, valleys
that are oriented south to north,
like for example the Rhine valley,
are much more Foehn-prone
than a valley that runs crosswise.
So the air mass
will come from the southern side
somehow onto the northern side of the Alps,
now in the case of South Foehn.
Accordingly there are special Foehn areas,
where you have to be especially careful.
Inform yourselves at the clubs,
at the flight schools, in the flying area,
on various websites,
where you find this information,
whether certain areas are Foehn-prone or not.
And really be conservative,
when it comes to Foehn areas.
There you see such a map,
you also find it at the SAV — it's really good.
That thing, to inform yourself with.
Here we have the last slide,
Foehn images, just
so that you've also seen it visually.
We have the beautiful lenticularis clouds
and we have a Foehn wall,
that's really like such a beautiful wall,
that forms like a claw
and the air mass that sinks down behind it,
which dries out.
And sometimes you really clearly
and clearly see that on the main Alpine ridge
a proper Foehn wall forms.
And if you see such a cloud,
that's never a good thing for flying
and will always cause turbulent winds,
when we talk about Foehn or otherwise also
strong wind.
Important, as I said, Foehn
doesn't always have to come together with these cloud forms.
It can also be a blue sky
and have no clouds and be Foehn.
That's important for you to know.
Now you've really discussed the three main dangers.
discussed.
We've covered the theory material,
because it's important for the theory exam.
I'd really also like to
lay it on your heart firmly,
to fly with the theory with open eyes,
to really engage with these topics,
to study these theory topics again and again
and especially, really important, in flight practice
to keep engaging with this topic.
Why do these clouds form now?
Why do I have wind now?
Why was it different now
than I expected?
Also look at the meteo forecasts,
which we also look at in another part,
how exactly you make a meteo forecast.
Engage with it,
talk to your flight instructor as much as you can.
Pester them during your training.
Also ask flying colleagues,
exchange your know-how,
also ask locals,
if you ever go anywhere who wants to travel,
for example wants to fly on an island.
Talk a lot with the locals about the weather phenomena
and you'll see, the more you learn here
and start to understand the principles,
us above all in practice
can put into action and see,
it works more and more,
that you've made the right forecast,
that you've flown to the right spot,
where you expected the thermal,
where you've made the right decisions,
the more it also starts to be fun
and I think especially meteorology
is really a very motivating topic
to put into action from theory into practice
and a lot of fun
and above all to be able to fly safely.
Right.
I now really wish you very nice flights,
learn well here, look in,
watch the videos again,
we also look forward to your feedback
and we wish you very nice flights
and a good time.
Bye.